who's the one that inspired you the man
to start fighting you or do you think it
was something that your dad
kind of set forth and this is this is
what it is
hey like biggest inspiration for me it
was my dad you know
it was my father yeah
all my life
you know it's like uh
i'm doing all these things only because
of him
only because of him you know it's like i
remember when i fight was like some
fights in ufc i just i call him after
fight right away i call him blank
and i try to get from him like some good
words you know
and he says like
and he beginning talk
about my mistakes what i make inside the
fight
and i'm listening to him listen like two
minutes and uh and i said okay you don't
want to say nothing to me he said it was
good job just come back we have to keep
training
you know it's like he was like for me is
like biggest motivation you know
he gave me good energy he gave me good
advice you know
and with him we knew like what we need
what we want you know like exactly and
like since when i was like
maybe like since 2005 2004
when i beginning training combat symbol
with father like
we have the goal you know it's like
become unc fighter
we have the goal but that time nobody
compete from russia and ufc and uh it
was very hard to sign
like when i signed end of the
2011 it was almost impossible sign with
the ufc like someone from russia yeah it
was like first athlete
and you know it was like
not many people believe us
but uh
when i see how father believe me how
really want this this is giving me like
crazy energy yeah did you have did you
have an inspiration like that mike i
know you always bring out roberto duran
you know him ali muhammad ali yeah
muhammad ali number one oh yeah
yeah
how cool was that for you mike to have
muhammad ali as your
you know obviously he was there when you
won your first world title yeah it was
just um
i met him in the olympics when i was 18
years old i met him then
but um
my manager was close friends and i
signed up to meet him and talk to him on
the phone
and he just inspired me i wanted to be
like him
yeah the charisma yeah
yeah what do you what do you think made
ali so special with the with the public
what was it about muhammad ali that made
him so special because he loved them
more than they loved him
that's the only difference isn't that
something he loved them more than they
loved him
yeah that's a trip man
just uh uh his spirit was just like a
glow right yeah there's some people have
that man you know what i mean i can i
don't i've
i regret mike not getting a chance to
like meet ali i was oh he loved you he
loved you yeah he uh did you i know you
find a lot of inspiration
muhammad ali
i think this guy this guy inspired not
only like fighters like athletes i think
millions of people around here yeah
businessmen everything yeah he was like
i think
bigger than just sport you know it's my
it's like
you know one of the famous
like human being of all time like i
think it's like yeah
like someone said like 1980 he was uh
number one famous human in the world
yeah yeah
he's like
and i remember like when you fight
it was uh
i remember 23rd february 2013
2003 like 18 years ago
you supposed to fight with clifford atn
and i was like
like week before the fight like all
russia media showed this fight or mike
tyson
uh gonna fight with clifford at 10 and
remember it it's supposed to fight like
five morning in uh moscow
time and i told my father please can you
make me wake up i really want to watch
this fight and me and my father
you watch your fight but you make me a
little bit upset because you knock him
out in first round i was waiting for
this i was waiting for it
to go
you know like
all this walk out to the
ring like he come you come like you know
it's like you got a party that yes like
i see my family gotta go it's like just
fight beginning again you put them on
slaves like i prayed with a lot thank
you and i was like what
and uh
i remember that time i remember with my
father i watched live you know
[Music]
you